by the way you like how he was like so
sharks you want to come take a swim at
the maritime industry are you scared to
the best this is the greatest thing I've
ever seen I thought this was gonna be
stupid these are these these are so much
better than anything we've ever done
with this they are so talented also if
this is like the bar if this is the
normal bar of college entrepreneur then
like uh you know like I feel like we
were playing basketball back in the days
when they had like short shorts and
nobody could use a left hand and like it
was a peach basket for a hoop it's like
oh wow
these guys can jump you know it's like
we just like LeBron just learned how to
lift weights like that's what this feels
like
[Music]
all right what up we got a special
episode this is like a shark tank style
episode so this is the my first million
pitch competition we got the University
of Michigan so Wolverines are here we
got five companies I believe each
company's gonna have two minutes to
pitch a five minute q a and the winner
will get five thousand dollars at the
end as decided by me and Sam whoever is
the best at pitching and little do
people know this
this is how I became an entrepreneur I
was going to be a doctor and then I
entered a pitch competition at my
University and I won that baby for 25
Grand and
um that was what got me on the path of
Entrepreneurship altogether I would have
never ever ever done startups uh if it
wasn't for that competition that we
randomly entered so
this could be kind of for somebody out
there this could be their break too so
here we go University of Michigan pitch
competition first up
um who is it Jake so Jake from area is
that right
yes hey guys
what's up all right two minutes is all
yours go
cool so hey guys my name is Jake I'm the
founder of area we're bringing
e-commerce abilities to in-person
shopping
and so as an e-commerce business owner
myself we we know quite a bit about our
customers such as who they are what
they're interested and how they engage
with our business
and so this this type of information
informs all aspects of our operations
from developing new products and then
driving more sales
and so
the question that comes to mind is why
aren't these same Necessities available
to retail business owners why is this
limited to just e-commerce and this
happens because the source of the
transaction which is the barcode
um at area we're making a new type of
product code that brings uh e-commerce
abilities to retail so this is called
one tag it uses radio frequency
identification
this is the same type of technology and
contactless credit cards and garage door
openers and it recently became
affordable at a mass scale and one Tech
is super versatile there's a lot of uses
for it it costs pennies to manufacture
and it's printed on a sticker to attach
to merchandise
uh so by replacing the barcode with one
tag retailers unlock new capabilities in
a variety of things I'm going to go into
one example now
so this is a traditional retail setup
you have your products then you have
barcodes and each one is individually
scanned
instead of that let's just replace all
these barcodes with one tag
so now uh
uh Shopper can just bag all items as
they shop
and then they can pretty much just walk
through an antenna which instantly scans
all of their items at once and then
payment can be done through a kiosk for
quick self checkout or through an app
that uses uh something called Ultra
wideband which is a new type of
Technology that's brought to iPhone and
as recent as 2019
and so
um this pretty much tracks the location
of the customer and shows what products
they purchased and how they purchased it
and so you could pretty much walk out
and then uh payments instantly process
as you walk out just like Amazon go so
what this does in addition to autonomous
checkout is it brings a bunch of
e-commerce capabilities to retail so now
we have an e-commerce profile for a
bunch of offline purchases and this
allows us to abandon car recovery
personalized product upsells
uh in-depth shopping data and
subscription reorders there's also loss
prevention built right in
and then
the location accuracy of RFID is super
high so Inventory management is like
pretty easy uh all you really have to do
is uh
is put an item in its proper location
and then
If an item is ever misplaced area pretty
much will map the entire location of all
these items and so instead of like
arduous stock checks
um you can pretty much just instantly
know where things are misplaced and
address those directly and so yeah
that's my product this is one tag it's
checkout security and inventory all in
one product and most importantly it
brings e-commerce abilities to retail
Jake what type of e-commerce storm do
you own
uh I own a sex chocolate brand
what is it called
it's called tabs chocolate yeah we we've
talked about you a fair bit uh on the
pot I think right you've got like a
crazy uh Instagram or Tick Tock or
something like that uh yeah we go viral
on Tick Tock pretty frequently yeah
that's cool wait you're in college
I am I'm a sophomore now my God okay uh
cool all right so Sam what do you think
yeah so I've talked to a few companies
in this space
I know there's a few people trying to
attack it and some of them I think are
actually quite big I the one of the most
interesting so basically
Jake explained it in a more
sophisticated way I'm going to explain
it in a more dumb way which is like this
little tag goes into clothing and you
know the clothing's history and you
could track it and things like that and
I saw a company that was doing this with
high-end luxury goods so like I don't
know if this was their customer but
basically like this would get sewn
inside of a Louis Vuitton purse and
whether you know how people buy and sell
used purses you could see like where it
originally came from who originally
bought it and as a collector of like old
stuff I thought that was awesome I
thought that was great so I it's
interesting technology to me I don't
really know this Market that well but I
do think there's a few people doing this
right Sean well I I think you are
looking only at a little niche use case
yeah yeah what you're doing is they're
trying to take the Amazon ghost store
like Amazon's like hey what if there was
a grocery store where you could walk in
and just walk out there's no checkout
process right that's more efficient it's
more convenient
um and it's lower cost because you don't
have to you know employ all these check
out Folks at the at the store and um
they're trying to just provide that as
like anybody any store should be able to
have that if they want kind of the uh
the next level of self-checkout as I
think what they're trying to do and so I
think that's a cool idea I think it it
takes a lot of boxes so
um technology that really wasn't
possible wasn't cheap enough until a few
years ago I like that like these little
I don't know if they're called I don't
know if these are NFC chips or whatever
but like they're very cheap like pennies
uh of these like
um the pennies like pennies now to to
manufacture or add these little chips to
um to any kind of goods so I think
that's really great that that's now
possible it wasn't possible before I
think it's clearly cheaper faster for
the person who's doing it um but I do
have some problems with your pitch so
I'm going to be like three bits of pitch
feedback for you all right Jake so
keep in mind though he's doing this with
like in the most like hood rat way ever
right now we've got like one person
talking another person hitting slides
and there's a delay so go a little
easier yeah yeah yeah and of course of
course and also he's like sideways on my
screen so that doesn't help uh but
basically the the
main things I would have said in the
pitch is basically like uh you know you
have three three major ways that you
could have presented this number one you
could have shown a barcode and just been
like
can you believe this hasn't been
upgraded in like a hundred years like
this is the same thing we've been using
for 75 years we got iPhones we got all
this crazy stuff all this amazing
technology but the barcode is still the
same and like you could have presented
it from that angle like the barcode is
is outdated we're we're revolutionizing
the barcode and the barcode's on
everything so like that's how big this
idea is going to be the second thing was
basically like we're taking the Amazon
go checkout and we're making it
available to any store right that that's
a very simple way for me to understand
what you're talking about
um so this the third thing is that you
have a really cool backstory with with
the chocolate stuff so you could be like
I'm Jake I'm a sophomore in college this
year I sold four million dollars worth
of sex chocolate
um I'm an entrepreneur I'm a hustler I
don't think my crew is gonna you know I
don't think sex chocolate's the big idea
for me but it led me to what I think is
the big idea and already I'd be hooked
because I'm like who is this college
sophomore that sold four million dollars
of sex chocolate like tell me more right
so that's my pitch feedback for you
um on that side on the on in the actual
idea itself the part I felt was lacking
was the go to market so this was this
was all about technology technology
technology but how are you going to get
customers and are you know are these
stores gonna be willing to revamp are
customers gonna understand what the hell
is going on and I think that's where
this technology that's where this
company like this would struggle but you
didn't really talk about that at all so
can you talk about about how are you
going to go get your first you know 10
or 100 customers have you done that
already or how are you going to do it
absolutely yeah I'm talking to customers
right now it would pretty much be there
would really be no retrofitting for a
store
um the first MVP would be pretty much an
iPad kiosk uh that's self-checkout so
but they have to tag every product right
they do yeah but a lot of retailers
especially small retailers don't even
use like Universal product code they
have to tag barcodes so it's not really
an increase in labor and um the way the
way I'm envisioning for the mdp is uh
customers already have to check out
somehow they go to the front desk
there's an iPad there that says instant
checkout they put their bag there and
pay with credit cards and then soon you
could add in things like uh antennas
with that inventory and then ultimately
it's hard to check out with an app so
who are you going for like small stores
big stores grocery stores clothing
stores huge Brands who are you going for
I'm thinking clothing stores and
convenience stores uh at least initially
so convenience stores give a lot of the
benefits of like the just walk out stuff
the convenience stuff and then clothing
stores uh prioritize the e-commerce
abilities a lot more to be able to
retarget customers and be a little bit
more pointed with the way they're
they're selling things Jake how old are
you I'm 20. how big is tabs uh it's
actually less than four million it's
about two million dollars this year
um got 800k profit and we started a year
ago today so for how young and how
impressive you are I have got incredibly
high standards because you're like
you're amazing I mean you're you're
you're you're you're you're you're
you're you're a certified badass with
your background and how young you are
thanks I am shocked at how much you're
you're screwing this up though like with
with this pitch because first you build
them up
my standards with him are so high
because like I'll I would invest in a
lot of things that this guy does just
because he's him uh I think if you're
that young and you're this successful
already like you clearly have some type
of it Factor uh Jonathan by the way can
you meet them you you clearly have some
type of mute factor or uh you have some
type of it factor sorry and uh you're
you're amazing I think though that when
Sean nailed it what he said that I don't
he didn't say it this way but basically
this isn't really a tech problem uh like
the tech exists and you're going to be
working on that this is a distribution
and marketing problem can you just get
this in the hands of the right people I
don't have a lot of experience selling
to like uh convenience stores and things
like that I think that would be a pain
in the ass unless you got like a
7-Eleven or something like that but like
I think going like from store to store
to store is gonna be the worst but
anyway uh I think this is like a
distribution customer acquisition
problem it's a sales problem yeah and
your problem and like if you're gonna
sell to a convenience store like the
dude who owns the convenience store is
working there that will tell you how
much he thinks about efficiency right
like he just sits there all day and like
if you're like hey you have 4 000 skus
on your shelves can you just add this
tab to it and then
when a customer comes in you could tell
them just to walk out he'd be like
actually it's fine they just I actually
want them to come to the front counter
so they buy a Five Hour Energy also and
a lotto ticket and like I don't want
them to just walk out that's like half
the revenue and so you know I think that
Pro that if I was you what I would say
is who needs this the mo well I guess if
I was you I'd probably actually lean on
your strengths you're like good at Tick
Tock and [__] like that that's my point
it's like you're good at shooting I'm
shocked that he doesn't get what people
are bad at you're doing a product that
old people would be good at which is
basically Enterprise sales going to
Kroger and showing them that with this
increase in efficiency or retargeting or
whatever they're gonna get you know it's
a four percent impact to the you know to
their to their operations and that's a
huge number for them but that takes
that's like a year-long rollout or
whatever I think the SMB sale problem is
going to be pretty tough here so that's
what I would say is the weaknesses but
really cool idea and
um The Good the good thing is I do think
this is inevitable like I do think this
is where all retail is going it's the
how is it going to get there that's sort
of the challenge and um so you know
that's you know that's that's the
opportunity also I think it's definitely
going to be challenging to acquire the
first initial customers the way this
works though is it gets easier over time
so you can build leverage with Brands
and have them install the tag itself
it's obviously a long-term goal
um but once it's you know similar to a
UPC where it's applied at checkout the
area to entry for a retailer to carry
area or carry One tech in their store is
virtually the same and a lot of these
benefits are actually pretty relevant to
um to retailers it's not really like
this kind of archaic like old thing
um so I think uh I think it's definitely
gonna be challenging to like go door to
door and pitch and I think there
definitely will need to be some sort of
investor or person that could intro me
to a bigger chain there where we could
like do an X do a roll out of this
that's much more efficient but um yeah I
mean you're definitely right it's gonna
take some some legwork to to get someone
on board if I was you there's a thing
called Walmart Labs you should check out
so Walmart has basically a giant
Innovation department or at least they
did I don't know if this is still around
but like they acquired a bunch of
startups they put like millions and
millions of dollars into Walmart Labs
where they were going to like experiment
with technology because Walmart's the
biggest retailer for them one percent
matters a lot and
um I would go talk to them and be like
hey here's what we're thinking about and
I think that conversation will be pretty
Illuminating
um to figure out like you know what's
the what is the appetite what are the
concerns what how would they
realistically you know how would you
realistically get this into stores so
that'd be my suggestion as a next step
and I actually think that a lot I know
I'm currently filming this in Austin
right now HEB has a like an innovation
lab I would I think Costco I imagine
would Sam's Club which is also Walmart
does but I think that as a 1920 21 year
old person with a really successful
background I think you actually have
this massive advantage to go to some of
these like Executives at some of these
big companies these gray-haired
Executives and they would meet someone
like you and they're like
you're you're special like it's my job
to like collect interesting talent and
like be on the latest and greatest and
know what's happening I uh I don't know
if you're gonna pull this off but like I
wanna I wanna be in business with you
and I think like three out of 20 people
who you talk to would give you a chance
just because of your success and your
age and I think that you should use
every Advantage you have do you think I
go to big retailers initially versus
small I have 100 whatever I would I
would go big right away I think big
retailers think about this stuff in a
more like they they need to be
innovating and these efficiencies mean a
lot more to them
um
and they can sort of mandate these
rollouts so so we so I think that's the
that's the play and Sam's totally right
there's going to be the executive who's
like love this you're gonna be like wow
he loves the technologies that they're
like he's gonna tell you you got to meet
my son he needs to be more like you and
it really like the draw is gonna be he
wants his 18 year old son to hang out
with you so that he could be more like
you and like you know that actually
could get you a long way that actually
happened to me several times in my like
basically between 18 and 24. I got so
many either investors or intros or
things like that just because people
just thought it was endearing that I was
this young kid who believed in this
stupid thing and was going for it and
was clearly smart and got to do things
later and uh they just wanted that
energy around them they wanted to
exactly support it they go I just want a
piece of the action I don't know what
it's gonna be but like when you see like
anyone who's like at the top often times
they'll be like I appreciate young
Hustlers who are like they're gonna be
the real deal I see myself in you
whatever it is and they build a
relationship and I would 100 use that
because there's like this like five or
six year window when you're still
considered a prodigy and you should just
like pounce on that right thanks Jake
thank you guys thanks Jake
um all right who's next we got anant
from internet activism
by the way that guy's pitch was like a
freaking Pixar movie or something it was
like animated and figma
like kids these days they got the tools
man I don't even know how do you do that
did you have you ever even seen that
before no that was all design and fig
but yeah that was impressive this this
one looks good too I like internet
activism I'm clicking on your deck now I
like your I like your hacker design it's
cool all right two minutes it's all
yours go all right my name is I'm the
CTO of an organization called internet
activism
So currently the world is online over 64
of the world has access to the internet
and the world's poorest communities
people are more likely to have access to
a cell phone than a toilet
but still the internet's potential when
it comes to Distributing humanitarian
software is heavily underutilized
in response to this internet activism is
the first non-profit that's solely
dedicated to developing software in
response to humanitarian disaster so now
I'm going to walk you through a couple
examples of what this actually looks
like in March 2022 we launched a website
called Ukraine take shelter this is
essentially like Airbnb for refugees we
connected refugees or potential hosts
and over the last year we've been we've
been able to house over a hundred
thousand refugees which has ten thousand
dollars in spend how did you track that
like you you know for a fact you put
them in their home
yeah another example of a project we
worked on is the world's most popular
coronavirus tracking dashboard this is
launched in January 2020 before covid-19
was officially a pandemic
it was used by over 600 million people
it was recognized by Dr fauji as an
invaluable resource in distributing
covid-19 information we were also
recognized as being able to compile
coronavirus data faster in the CDC and
sharing it with General Public
and now moving on to what we're doing
right now we're building out an app
called hyperlocal this essentially
allows people to message each other just
using Bluetooth so if you don't have
access to data or Wi-Fi or cellular
service you can still message others
using Bluetooth even if they aren't
right near you we can carry store and
forward messages so messages can hop
between people across large distances
this app is completely decentralized
it's censorship resistant and it's
secure and we envisioned this to soon be
a vital part of the modern day emergency
toolkit
so the central thesis for our
organization is being low cost having a
quick response time and having building
with small teams
we're going to build out an entire Suite
of products that we can tweak in the
matter of days or hours to respond to
crises around the world and our main
goal is to bridge the gap between the
tech sector and humanitarian
organizations
our leadership consists of the world's
leading internet activists exited
Founders and highly talented designers
and developers we're all young ambitious
and we build really really fast
and when crisis occurs next we'll be
ready to respond
and move on to questions wow wow that
was incredible did you yeah you who are
you these people are [__] amazing by
the way how old are you how old are you
21. and you're in college
yeah why
I'm asking myself that question too
probably gonna take like a gap semester
or a permanent Gap semester starting
next month this is amazing well done
um
from the start the pitch was amazing uh
you know the world's poorest communities
are more likely to have a cell phone
than access to a toilet um that is uh
you know a great attention grabbing you
know like you know grabbing by the
throat type of type of uh hook and then
then you backed it up and you were like
you know we're gonna do this thing we're
going to basically develop soft
non-profit developing software for the
humanitarian disaster okay it sounds
interesting but you've actually done it
so super impressive that you guys did
this Airbnb thing and you housed a
hundred thousand refugees
um I remember using this coronavirus
tracker uh yeah it's made
um so that's kind of amazing as well and
it sounds like how much traffic did you
say that one got it had over 600 million
users and a peak daily active 36 million
use 34 million iliac abusers and how did
it get so popular what did you do did
you just release it to the world did it
just went or was there any growth in
marketing around it I believe it was
because of how early it was released
this was before John Hopkins started
like publicly aggregating all the data
and releasing it we just had an
advantage of being like one of the first
people to compile all this data and
share it with everyone again this was in
January 2020 so this was three months
before like the pandemic officially
began this was just in the early stages
of the pandemic and so you said this you
show this leadership team which is three
people how many people are there total
in your group or your org that like
actively do stuff currently there are
five people wow so you're a five person
Team all of you guys are like you know
college age is that it yeah everyone's
in between the ages of 19 and 21. have
you made any money from any of us
government grants
um donations we're 501c3 so we're going
to be raising over the next few months
that okay so our Grand Vision right now
is
we're just going full force with a
non-profit right now so these are like a
couple cool projects but this is small
in comparison to what we're going to do
over the next few years we want to build
that entire Suite of tools so that
whenever a crisis occurs we can just
tweak it and then quickly deploy in a
matter of hours or days if you like
current non-profits the amount of time
it takes to respond to a situation it
can be months it can be years we want to
be able to do that in hours
how many non-profits are like run by
hackers right no one does this that's
why so we worked on these projects in
the past and we're like why is no one
else doing this we see how powerful the
internet is in terms of Distributing
these Solutions we see that can
literally save lives so if no other
organization is going to do it we're
going to do it but why is there an
incentive for a for-profit investor this
isn't for profit this is more we're
going to be taking donations we're a
non-profit organization but is there a
way okay
maybe there's a philosophical reason why
you're doing it which is totally which
is cool that I won't I won't debate you
on that but yeah no we can talk about
that if if we do make this a for-profit
company and we're going into countries
where we're establishing a presence
we're becoming they're like Central
means of communication if we come across
as a for-profit company people are going
to question whether maintenance
incentives are again we're not trying to
distribute this in like one or two
countries with the app that I was
discussing before hyper local
and that okay I'm just gonna walk you
through that app real quick basically it
allows people to just message each other
using Bluetooth so if a government shuts
down Wi-Fi access like we're seeing in
Iran right now you can still message
people close to you or across an entire
city you can balance message across
everyone in between you and that person
who has our app downloaded even if their
phone is off so if this will become this
has happened before right these mesh
Network like messaging apps and they
kind of took off I remember when at
festivals where there was no service and
then in some like disaster zones they
were using these the thing is that most
of these Mesh networking apps they're UI
and ux sucks we're gonna improve that
and they don't have store and carry so
say you're standing near me I can
message you pretty easily but if I want
to message someone who's a mile away my
message cannot get to them what we're
doing is essentially and first of all
our messages are completely encrypted
but say I want to message someone who's
on the other side of a city if I want to
message them every person I come across
I will they will will store my message
and be like Anan is trying to message
this other person so once they walk
across other people they're also going
to be carrying my message until it
eventually reaches that person so you're
able to create like a virus effect and
spread messages and create entire
decentralized networks and cities what
are you and your team motivated by why
are you doing this we want to like have
a positive impact in the world basically
we know that there are existing
solutions that can help out people
around the world we know that we can
potentially save lives or just make the
world a jet better place in general but
just to just to reiterate this is not a
profit making thing and that is not your
intention ever you're just doing this
because I imagine it's incredibly fun
and because you just want to make the
world better is that right yeah
basically look if you if you see that
there's a problem in the world and you
know that you have the means to create a
solution for it if you walk away from
that solution our entire team would
basically be bystanders and our team
isn't bystanders man this was this was
great um
you're a Visionary I mean I think this
guy's [__] badass yeah I think what
you guys have done is amazing I think
that uh it's really cool to see a
non-profit that's just driven by a you
know a handful of Builders like in
Engineers to hackers for better lack of
a better word and um
not gonna lie gonna be a hard pitch to
beat so you know uh I'm just gonna put
that out there the ball is starting off
so our team is five people but we're
planning on scaling this as fast as
possible half of our team right now is
full-time students I'm a computer
science student here at University of
Michigan I have a lot of workload but as
soon as this semester ends this is all
we're going to be working why hasn't
University of Michigan been like dude
bail here's money you're good that would
be a good question for the University
yeah about both both of the first two
pitches got the my first million uh
bachelor's degree you know you got to be
a badass uh from our from us you don't
need to finish school the one thing you
should do though is you should shout out
if there's because people listen to this
podcast if there's somebody at a school
right now or young young person who's
like dude that's awesome I want to help
them out yeah okay there's a website
internetactivism.org if you go to that
you can find your contact information
and reach out to us directly all right
internet Beyond just people are
interested in programming for us if
you're interested in working with us and
a non-profit organization or you're just
philanthropic in general
feel free to reach out to us we're
looking for as many partners in both the
tech and humanitarian space as possible
I want to reach as many people as
possible within the next few years all
right you're saving the world yeah yeah
all right very good you're perfect we
love you you're amazing but by the way
he hit him with the uh if you don't want
to sell sugar water exactly
amazing dude um
I I these guys are so much smarter than
us
these guys are amazing dude I was
picking my boogers at that age and
eating Chick-fil-A and now I still eat
Chick-fil-A I just stop picking boogers
right like these guys are so far ahead
of where where I was in college I was
it's noon on a Friday I was gearing up
for the nighttime bar run for my hot dog
stand like I was like getting I was
chopping onions in my kitchen getting
ready for the 2 A.M Hot Dog Rush these
guys are so to build a website that has
600 million people visit it that is
outstanding this is just these these
these guys are crazy yeah
um I I don't get like the whole not I
would I would urge him I mean I could go
either way I would urge him to have a
for-profit way of doing this because I
think no no he's doing it perfectly what
are you gonna live on grants your whole
life I mean how does it like first of
all like Jonathan move this guy there's
a lot of money in government grants out
there it's not like we're gonna be
starving or anything we can sew afford
to like sustain ourselves we also have
people like Jake in our community so if
you want to work on side businesses we
have that offer opportunity unlocked too
but we thought that we're this is like
you know when people go to Teach for
America for two years like go work for
internet activism.org and uh you'll come
out the other side you know in a good
spot don't worry about that all right so
let's do the next one next one is uh
Jordan is gonna pitch us your feet
by the way I'm inspired I want to quit
this enjoy that if I could hop in for
two seconds uh I'm Bobby and also like
anyone who's watching this we are a
group of entrepreneurs this is built for
students by students in my community
these people are my best friends and if
you want to like get involved with these
people in any sort of way like feel free
to reach out to me at
b-h-o-u-s-e-l-u-mesh
umich.edu we're building communities
like this across the country and we want
your help if you're a college student a
young person that's excited about making
things but uh I'll let the next guy go
all right what's up Jason from what is
it Seafair seal Fair Seafair and from
Minnesota
all right hit it you got two minutes
awesome Ahoy sharks this is Seafair
payroll and onboarding software for
ships
let's just jump right into the problem
here
paying the 2 million Global seafarers is
really hard the average ship is made up
of people's from more than three
different nationalities meaning you deal
with disparate local bank accounts
currencies and regulations that's why
the current solution is literally paying
these people in US dollars cash and or
sending slow and often delayed Swift
transfers on top of this the documents
that seafarers need to provide and that
ships need to process are arduous and
painstaking to go through
take a look at this Sam I can see your
face right now you're having flashbacks
to the DMV when you try to renew your
license it's an absolute disaster to go
through these documents we're talking
vaccinations professional certificates
sailing history you name it they have to
provide it once the affair I talked to
once had to print out 700 pages of
documents just to get hired on a ship by
the way what's a seafare are we talking
like uh like work ships or what yeah
we're talking Merchant Mariners so any
ship that's out in the ocean primarily
those like transporting goods and
services but outside like Leisure as
well as military ships yeah awesome so
what are my brother and I working on to
address this problem we're taking a
two-pronged approach to this solution
first is with the payroll solution we're
talking multi-currency low FX fees
direct deposit to local accounts and a
mobile first approach that will bring
this industry to the modern era this
will improve record-keeping and
financial management for these ships and
will eliminate the risk of having cash
on board I'm sure many of you have seen
the movie Captain Phillips and know this
problem at hand second is we're working
on an onboarding solution for ships this
will be a single place where they can
have a document upload where our
software will scrape those documents to
determine eligibility expirations and
everything else a ship needs to know
saving them money seafarers will love it
too as it'll be a One-Stop shop for them
to store their documents track their
certifications and have an employment
record at hand
so sharks why now there's two compelling
reasons why this can happen right now
first is that fintech infrastructure
over the past few years has exploded
never has it been easier faster more
efficient and more reliable to build a
cross-border payments company
second internet adoption on ships is
finally growing if you didn't know a lot
of these ships didn't have access to
Internet until recently but the drop in
cost of satellite internet and starlink
for maritime launching in just this July
we see it really exploding on top of
this there's a labor shortage of
seafarers right now which is putting
pressure on shipping companies to
provide internet in order to attract
labor to work for them
so sharks I'll leave you with a quote
from Captain Jack Sparrow and in the
meantime I'm happy to answer any
questions that you have
Bravo man you guys are all great this is
the this is way like we had stocks we
did this with stocks and it was like
these like you know people who have been
working in the workforce for years and
some of them already successful
entrepreneurs
this is way better
this is way better this is really good
um what was your name again Jordan uh my
name is Jason okay it's Jason
um Jason I'd like to invest in your
company so I don't know if you're gonna
win this pitch competition or not but
I'd like to invest in your company so
all right let's set up a call next week
no call I'm in uh the call is done this
is this was the call and I'm in uh I
don't know if you have an entity or a
corporation but you need to get one and
send me some wiring details uh because
I'm in on this idea this is a you know
one of my best investments was a company
called deal that's basically like a
payments solution for contractors around
the world
this is like a niche that no no payment
companies gonna really like kind of
focus on the unique aspects of this
um no none of the modern companies are
going to do this you know I think
because there's probably a bunch of
nuances that are specific here it seems
like
you could go in and you know you found a
problem that most people aren't even
really aware of like I didn't even know
what a Seafarer was for the first two
minutes of the presentation
um you know so I doubt most
entrepreneurs are even looking at this
the question of course is how big can
this be so let's just do some math here
two million
two million uh what are we I'm not
calling these guys
through the Tam calculations if you want
quick yeah so what is the how much money
can you make if you get like you know
whatever let's say um you know some
reasonable amount of like if you had a
tenth of that so if you had 200 000 of
these people using your platform what
would you be generating
okay yeah so 200 000 we're charging ten
dollars a month okay so that's two
million dollars every single month times
12.
um that's 24 million in in ARR if we
capture 10 of the market but you also
have to realize that we're going to be
charging and sort of monetizing not just
based off ten dollars per person per
month we're also going to be taking 25
to 50 bips on FX as well as getting
floating interest on payroll deposits
before they're sent out so I would say
as you know we left your ten percent
markets
yeah that's that's say I'm safe word
okay so I think I'm clear I'm in on this
I will invest in this company Sam what
are your thoughts it is I'm I'm taken
away uh or my breath has taken away
these guys are awesome man uh like the
reason this is great is this guy's
pitching a Seafair B2B software but at
the bottom of a slide he says Alexa Play
I'm On A Boat by Lonely Island uh like
this the the dichotomy here going on of
just a bunch of dumbass [__] young
kids who are [__] Geniuses and
Incredibly successful I'm all about it
you know I said earlier in the first
pitch you do a good job pitching to some
older executive who just wants to be
around you guys that's exactly how I
feel right now so your your brother says
five years of AWS so is this your
brother who's older and out of college
yeah
in a computer engineering degree he's
been working at AWS for five years this
is currently just an idea right you
don't have a product you don't have any
customers or anything like that yup idea
phase did you work with uh Bessemer yep
I worked at Bessemer Adventure Partners
last summer did you pitch them this
no I did not Pitch the mess why not uh
they primarily do series a but I'm happy
to talk to some of my partner friends
there after this why didn't uh how did
you come across this idea yeah yeah so
my brother was actually born in
Indonesia he spent a lot of time there
and you might know them as like a global
shipping hub so he actually became
friends with this guy named Dennis long
story short is Dennis handled a lot of
the payroll paperwork that has to be
processed by these shipping companies
and uh he would talk to my brother
basically every day about the pain
points he faced so uh we decided we
should tackle this to help alleviate
some of Dennis's pain here is that how
you know them Sean Indonesia as a
shipping hub yeah I lived in Indonesia
and I didn't pay attention to any of
this [__] I met a guy named Poppy who
was it was importing cotton yeah I was
like whoa shout out to Poppy if he's
listening somewhere uh yeah I still
remember you so do you how will you sell
this so who do you who are you gonna go
to and like is the guy going to have
like you know gangrene on his no
Knuckles I'd be like what are you
talking about apps you know like who are
you going to be selling this to and what
makes you think you could sell it yeah
for sure for sure so I know I look
pretty young here but I do have a past
life uh doing sales at several early
stage successful software companies uh
most notably patch.io join them pre-seed
they're now at series B so I've put in
my thousand cold calls put in my 100 000
cold emails so I'm pretty confident that
I can get on the phone with someone and
sell something
um I will say that people were targeting
right this is a fairly concentrated
industry a lot of the shipping companies
control lots of like market share so
it's pretty long sales Cycles Enterprise
B2B sales Cycles but I directly reach
out to sort of those working in the
offices of these shipping companies get
them on the phone and sort of kick off
that cycle I'm projecting six to ten
months for the average sales cycle for
these bigger companies
um but obviously we're going to work our
way down to smbs later on Jason is your
Jason right
uh yeah I'm so hot and bothered when you
talk to me like this did somebody script
this for you why are you saying all the
right things all right so this is great
Jason email me Shawn perry.com I'm
investing in this company I can't wait
uh this is this is really really
interesting uh well well done good pitch
um all right next one up we got are we
going back to it thanks boys
are we going back by the way you like
how he was like so sharks you want to
come take a swim at the maritime
industry these kids are the best this is
the greatest thing I've ever seen I
thought this was gonna be stupid these
are these guys are so much better than
anything we've ever done with this they
are so talented also if this is like the
bar if this is the normal bar of college
entrepreneur then like uh you know like
I feel like we were playing basketball
back in the days when they had like
short shorts and nobody could use their
left hand and like it was a peach basket
for a hoop it's like oh wow
guys can jump you know it's like we just
like LeBron just learned how to lift
weights like that's what this feels like
I don't know what's happening by the way
he's hoping this next one sucks I really
hope he sucks just so I feel better this
guy Jason was supposed to go last but he
just interrupted and grabbed the mic
like cognated with Taylor Swift because
he goes hey bro can I take this over I
gotta run to class like can we just
reiterate that if I was University of
what is this University of Michigan uh
they seem like a fairly Progressive
school if I like was these guys and I
heard what was happening I would say bro
it was like don't go to class anymore
here's here we got you covered do this
stuff by the way I want to do this with
like every University now this is
amazing uh I need to know if it's just
the University of Michigan thing or if
this is that's like the caliber of
entrepreneurs uh Jonathan what should we
if you're another University or if
you're somebody at a university
listening to this how do they get in
touch with us to do this at their school
it is it is definitely partially a
Michigan thing and I will say like the
biggest problem is the universities
don't facilitate this it took me like
two years to meet every single one of
these killers and like we come together
at bi-weekly to bring together these
kinds of conversations and to build
together
I'm a student as well yeah this is a
community of entrepreneurs like 200
strong at this school we meet bi-weekly
and just enjoy each other no context of
like paying dues like monthly membership
like screw that this is not a club this
is just a group of killers that enjoy
spending time together
got a good [__] man this does not exist
at other schools and the schools that
like pretend like they have these crazy
entrepreneurship programs like no hate
on Mission entrepreneurship like there
are some upside like they can't build
this right like this has only existed
because I spent every waking moment at
this school like any time anyone tells
me they're building something new
Scooter Braun man what yeah
I would love to help put this on other
schools like our mission is to bring
this sort of community to schools across
the country right like built Ground Up
For Students five students screw the
preconception of having to do anything
like yeah come and be together and like
make cool [__] all right Bob
that was incredible but also just the
bi-weekly Killers that's a great band
right there yeah it's like a doo-wop
band from the 60s
this data is wrong every freaking time
have you heard of HubSpot
HubSpot is a CRM platform where
everything is fully integrated well I
can see the client's whole history calls
support tickets emails and here's a test
from three days ago I totally missed
HubSpot grow better
put your fi on I want to hear from
Jordan Shamir
yeah no thanks for having me I guess I'm
the senior citizen here I'm a master's
student so a little bit older but if we
go to the next slide one of the things
we were working on in a previous life is
we were all working on digital
identities how can these Brands create
you know meaningful consistent
relationships with their customers
customers are always changing but one of
the things that we saw is that our
understanding of who customers are
digitally is really complicated we can't
interact with them we can't see them we
can't see what they like and so one of
the things that we did is we actually
worked with some of the world's largest
Brands right working in the bot
mitigation team so I don't know if y'all
like sneakers or anything along those
lines one of the things that we saw is
that through all of our experience in
e-commerce but just larger brands in
general is that everything you consume
digitally is being skewed because
everyone has multiple personas or
multiple identities online so whether
it's intentional being Bots frauds
resellers Etc or unintentional right
we've all used multiple different email
addresses to get 10 15 off discounts and
this crazy is a huge issue for both
Brands and consumer rumors right from
Brands I don't know how many customers
that I have are unique I don't know
which products to build because it's
being skewed by these multiple personas
I over forecast inventory leads to a
bunch of dead stock but also as
consumers right we all know what's going
on with Taylor Swift or we've all lost
sneaker drop we've all paid way too much
for a concert ticket that we wanted to
go to the reason it happens it's not
because other people are beating you
it's because people are programmatically
beating you with Bots and the second
thing that I also you know that we see
that's just fascinating is that the
notion of omnichannel has changed
drastically you're not just competing
Nike versus Adidas you're also competing
Nike versus you know d2c Nike Dick
Sporting Goods Nike unauthorized
resellers and these unauthorized
resellers are actually costing Brands
millions and dollars a year even Dum
Dums lollipops like the ones that you
get from you know the hospital or the
doctor is actually being Arbitrage and
it's costing them millions of dollars a
year and then we kind of know about
these fake profiles on Twitter and you
know these social media sites that we've
seen or even if you live in New York
Austin La you know if you try to go to
your favorite restaurants big reason why
they're booked is that the moment they
come online they're taken and resold
somewhere else so what we've done is
we've actually created a platform like
in a digital identity platform we're in
real time without like interacting with
the user we rank every order between
zero and one hundred so we kind of use
this real-time glass uh graph networking
clustering to be able to find all these
patterns of Randomness and associations
between individuals and we create these
really nice graphs to be able to say
okay well these are Bots these are Bad
actors these are duplicate accounts and
so we actually work with some of the
largest neighborhood sneaker stores in
the world to help them prioritize hey I
got a whole bunch of raffle entries
right I got 400 000 raffle injuries for
50 pairs of shoes how do I use this to
acquire new clients or prioritize
existing ones how do I choose because
today what they're doing is they're just
randomly giving it out and people aren't
actually buying them because people
aren't even checking the email addresses
that are going in so we've been actually
working with a lot of this from Bad
actors perspective but one of the new
things that we've been able to see with
this which has been really cool is
helping Brands actually find their best
customers so kind of through using the
same clustering technology we've been
able to say who are your most
influential customers right how are they
not just their individualized can we
pause let's blow a circle yeah I think
that might be over the two minutes so
um
Sam can you tell me can you tell me what
this guy does what is the business yeah
you're missing your one-liner my friend
but basically uh it's a software that
has 160 features that analyze in real
times the patterns of random randomness
and similarities at the customer
transactional Product Company it's it's
confusing dude can you explain that
Jordan can you explain it to me like
this we help
blank customer who's your customer what
type of person or business oh we help
Brands and retailers more specific like
give me one example like we help shoe
brands or something yeah we help Brands
like Nike to prioritize their best
consumers for limited release products
and also clean their data by pulling out
kind of all the crap that goes in I
don't so prioritize their top customers
you basically you tell Nike who their
top customers are we would say like for
sneaker drops and limited release
products like hey these are the new
clients that you can acquire cheaply or
hear the clients that you can actually
prioritize that this is actually
something meaningful compared to one
person putting like 10 000 or a hundred
thousand entries via Bots to get those
products so you just prevent Bots from
buying [__] online we prevent and then
what we also do is we actually kind of
clean the data Downstream so we flag all
of those accounts that can get pulled
out of the CRM system that are kind of
bloating the CRM system so like one of
the things that we see from a lot of our
clients is that they way overspend on
you know the products that they use like
clavio or you know kind of CRM products
because a lot of the entries in there
aren't actually legitimate so when I'm
actually making decisions around how
many products should I buy or how many
products should I make what are people
buying it's actually being skewed based
off the amount of what's in there is
actually just a bunch of duplicate
versus actually unique consumers okay
you are not the best at explaining your
own company but that but you're not
horrible I kind of get it after you
explain it a bunch and but that's all
good you can think you can improve that
but do you have any
um even on your website man I'm gonna be
honest it's a little challenging to
understand but I saw that you have a
book demo thing do you are you booking
demos are you do you have a product are
people buying it yeah we have about 25
customers right now that's impressive
what's the revenue the revenue right now
when we convert to revenue is going to
be around 15K mrr but it's free now is
what you're saying it's free right now
yep you need notable customers that you
know like are
anybody we would know of
um I guess like based off the area
you're in we work with a lot of like
local sneaker stores so like in San
Francisco we work on with a couple of
same in Seattle same in Canada so mostly
local sneakers do they love it and be
honest do they love it do they like it
or do they think it's just okay they
love it I mean right now we're providing
from our cost to Value we're providing
for like if we're charging them a
thousand dollars one of their stores
we're providing ten thousand dollars in
net new Revenue that we're acquiring in
for them a month
okay okay
um you know honestly it's tough to give
you feedback because the pitch was so
confusing
um
so it's really difficult to try to
assess that out right like just from the
beginning you know like Sam said you
need your one-liner or your one sentence
description so that people need to have
a clear picture in their head at the
beginning of the presentation what the
business does all right so you here's
your first slide your first slide said
yofi keep business human all right cool
no idea what you do then I go to your
second slide it's a team side experts at
transforming data into recommendations
our passion is keeping customer
interactions authentic and meaningful
still have no idea what you guys do
then slide three everything is digital
and you've been impacted and it says
something about ticket sellouts and fake
social media and brand loyalty is harder
okay still don't know what you do
and then the last one which is
prioritize and reward your best
customers we help you understand your
customers and streamline every
interaction
I feel like there's 50 different ways
that that could be described like that
could mean 50 different uh Solutions and
so and then the last slide is just your
title again right so that was the whole
pitch and so that's the that's I think
the challenge here is for me at least
I'm not able to really give you any
useful feedback except for except for to
say
I think you gotta like flip this on its
head and say
we're yofi uh and we help you know we
help businesses figure out who their
most valuable customers are for example
this is a shoe store the shoe store does
drops every Friday but it's having this
problem which is blah blah blah and
that's a common problem so we give them
this app that shows them a screen like
this and these are all the top customers
they push this button and our app costs
a thousand dollars a month and look at
this our we have 25 customers and on
average we make them 10 grand a month in
additional revenue and we also save them
an additional thousand dollars a month
because of the bloated CRM and like they
don't actually need those contracts in
there and then all these other reasons
yeah and then you go you know then you
could go on and here's why you know we
even found this problem because we've
spent our career doing this blah blah
right so I think that's how I would try
to reorient this pitch if I was you but
the good news is is as you got into it
and we were able to like work hard to
kind of find the gold and all the dirt
you had some good [__] in there it does
actually seem like an interesting
product is that it's pretty impressive
that you're have all these people using
it you're saying they love it I have no
idea if that's true but you're saying
they love it that's really interesting
that's hard to do with the software
product when you're just working on it
part-time so it seems actually fairly
interesting I think your branding is
kind of cool
um but your messaging
um
needs a lot of work yeah that's helpful
yeah and that's been our hardest thing
is like we kind of matured it's like
getting the messaging spot on because
like we do a little bit more right we
started with sneaker Bots now we've kind
of expanded more to digital identity so
having like a streamlined messaging of
like what we do that's like a one-liners
but I think you're making a common
mistake which is we do a bunch of things
we don't have just one customer we have
like five five different types of
customers and we do we have 100 features
in our app so we do a bunch of things so
what you do is you try to create this
giant umbrella that's a catch-all like
we help custom we help Brands understand
their customers or streamline their
customer interactions and the problem is
nobody knows what the hell that means so
instead you should go way narrower and
be like uh you know whoever you're most
of the 25 clients is there one type
that's like you know the majority or
half a half of the customers is it shoe
stores secret stores yeah right now it's
uh yeah sneaker store and Beauty
so I would start by saying we help
stores do X for example we have 25
customers right now and half of them are
sneaker stores sneaker stores have this
problem blah blah you talk about that
you say but it's not just sneaker stores
because yes sneakers do drops but so
does Taylor Swift she does drops too and
so does this brand they do drops too and
they all have that same problem right
and so that's kind of how you should
explain it instead of trying to do this
like an umbrella thing
um okay cool uh thanks so much we got
the we got one more I believe
yeah
we got
we got Dolan from deal dog that's going
to take us home Dolan from deal dog all
right wonderful awesome so my name is
Dolan and uh I create a deal though
so deal dog's an exclusive campus
Marketplace we launched this semester at
the University of Michigan beginning
with student football tickets and since
then our traction has been good we have
over 2 000 verified Michigan students on
the app and those 2000 students have
processed over ninety three thousand
dollars of student tickets uh
additionally with some traction numbers
two-thirds of those tickets that have
been listed on Deal dog have been sold
to other users and we're growing in the
next few months
so what's the core problem essentially
the way students buy and sell things on
campus now is they go to group me or
Facebook Marketplace those are filled
with Bots and scammers uh and basically
it's just a mess next they need to go to
a platform like LinkedIn or Instagram to
message the other person or verify the
legitimacy finally they need to transact
payment and there's friction between
these LDS cash app there's a chicken in
the egg problem versus who sends the
item first and who pays first and
overall it's just a complete mess
so what makes deal dog different first
of all we verify your umish email so you
can't get into the app unless you have a
verified student email it's a
centralized place to find relevant items
to students along with tools like
filtering sorting and searching so
here's an example on the left of what
our app looks like if you were to log in
versus on the right this is the the
current state of the market full fill
the scammers and Etc
so what makes deal dog actually
different
so our app has gamified tools that turn
student pain points into Fun experiences
one of which that I demonstrated here is
our tool called final offer basically if
you're dealing with somebody they're
wishy-washy you can't reach uh you know
agreement on price you can use our final
offer tool to send them your best offer
if they reject it the conversation's
over and if they accept it you know you
agree to sell them that item This is
highly scalable because when we expanded
to New Markets we can add tools into
this toolbar exactly like you do with
imessage just help solve those needs
understand
so how does the scale this two is one of
which is we're going to expand to
different categories on campus we just
launched the clothing and have great
success uh our approach is to build
things from the ground up instead of
cloning other markets uh and again with
our chat tools
Integrations we're thinking about or to
integrate on top of the apis of existing
clothing platforms so that for instance
if you want to find Michigan gear you
can't find exactly what you're looking
for on our app it'll redirect you to an
existing platform and although we may
lose that particular sale we want to
make that buying experience as easy as
fast and safe as possible for students
so our future plans are to expand to new
campuses uh we're going to build on top
of the dominant ticketing apis that
exist in the market today and
additionally we're going to have an
ambassador program so we can scale even
faster both at Michigan and at other
schools does this exist now or is this
just an idea
so this exists now uh it's been live for
about two months just at Michigan we
wanted to really validate our hypothesis
and see what works with students and
what doesn't work did you think he was
making up the traction numbers or what I
didn't see it wait I first slide he's
like we have 2 000 students
and that's in two months that's pretty
impressive uh
huh okay
and what was your take on that you take
ten percent yeah so one of the things
that we wanted to hold off on is
actually implementing the payments we've
already built it but we didn't want to
implement it yet because we're so new uh
we thought it'd be a little uh it'd be a
point of friction for students to be
like hey you know we're launching this
new app by the way what's your credit
card number put in your banking details
stuff like that uh we wanted to really
get the product down first before we
started actually you know taking money
between the two parties when we do it's
going to be between five and ten percent
of whatever the transaction is okay
uh all right cool thanks Sean what do
you think yeah I think it's cool
um I like some of the product details
like I love the final offer thing I
think that's great and I get it that
like
you know Craigslist Facebook Marketplace
these things are like lower trust so
having verified student IDs I think it's
just great because it creates this like
trust bubble so I really like that um I
don't know how big this gets so that'd
be my kind of question I don't really
like these kind of like small take rate
businesses where you take five or ten
percent
then you need the number to be massive
on the transaction side in order for you
to like make a lot of money
um so I think that's the only question
is just like I think this is really it's
a useful product I think it's a cool
project to work on
um I wouldn't personally invest in this
because I don't think it can be that big
you would have to basically take a
Facebook path where you would say we're
gonna go get every College we're going
to dominate that college it's going to
be like the way that you transact in a
in a trusted environment and then you
say okay but it's not just colleges now
we're going to do neighborhoods because
we can send postcards out and verify
that you live at the address like
Nextdoor does and we're gonna you know
you'd have to really believe
that like two or three more miracles are
gonna happen for this to be big
um so I think that's my only that's my
only knock on it which is not really
like you know
not every business has to be absolutely
massive it's just when I invest I try to
obviously slant towards things but it's
the Network's effects it's a net in this
business involves a network so in order
for it to be successful everyone needs
to be using it so my problem is not with
Dolan the entrepreneur my problem is
with this Market uh I think that even if
you are a 10 out of 10 entrepreneur this
is just like social apps even if you're
a 10 out of 10 entrepreneur and you have
10 out of 10 execution
it's just like it's so challenging to
make this work you're going for like a
four out of ten opportunity yeah it's
just it's just so hard because you got
you're competing with Craigslist you're
competing with um Facebook marketplace
now you're gonna be competing with the
other incumbents that have raised
hundreds of millions of dollars that are
I think mostly failing like what was
that thing called let's OfferUp offer up
in Lego or Le something like that they
bought Billboards they did everything
they possibly could I don't think it's
caught on uh and it's like well they
prop the entrepreneurs I bet were really
great they've raised hundreds of
millions of dollars so Capital wasn't an
issue and yet they still can't beat
Craigslist which is just 30 dudes in an
apartment working at which is I know
this because I rented their apartment it
was like a crappy apartment it's just 30
guys who are hippies and they're just
like where it's like well
you're just not going to beat us because
everyone already uses this so it's like
it doesn't matter how great you are uh
and so it's really really hard you have
so many things going against you and I
want to invest in things that have
Tailwinds and I just don't think that no
matter how great you are you're going to
catch a tidal wave I think you're always
going to be paddling you know Upstream
on this one yeah really good points we
certainly have a lot to prove uh one of
the things that we wanted to do is hey
begin with college campuses the reason
being is because you know at these big
large State schools you got a student
body of 50 60 000 people competing for
10 000 tickets and in that exact Niche
you know the math really makes sense but
I do agree in a lot of other cases it
might not uh one of the things that
we're expanding to working on if I may
is a lot of these items that we're
working on whether it be tickets
second-hand Goods Services subletting uh
the core mechanics of those can be
distilled down and then scaled to other
things so for instance if a campus group
has a concert they bring a DJ whatever
the case may be they can use our app an
underlying ticket technology to
distribute that on campus and so again
it doesn't solve your core uh issue of
you know it's a credibly difficult
Market certainly I think that makes it
worse actually I think that one of the
few ways that these business one of the
few ways these businesses can work is by
like being very Niche so you have
Poshmark for women's clothing you've got
um uh grail for men's streetwear uh you
know there's like dozens of these that
are like pretty big companies I think
Poshmark is a multi-billion dollar
company thredup I don't know what their
Niche is but some type of like clothing
for a certain genre a person I think
that when you appeal to everyone you
appeal to no one and I think that and
really to make this work you'd have to
select like I'm sure that there's what's
the one call for tennis or for sneakers
stockx or something like that yeah code
yeah yeah like these are huge businesses
because they just focused on one thing
and it's far easier to have a wedge
where you start with a small group of
people who are passionate and care about
them and get them to use it versus well
we're gonna do tickets and then we're
gonna do this and then we're gonna do
this it's like no man I think you just
build a big thing you just focus on this
one thing and so appealing to everyone
so sublets
um so Apartments uh and then tickets and
then you had clothing on your deck I
think that's actually in my opinion
turns me off even more not again not
entirely on you I just think that like
there's just so many things outside of
your control you know like Seafair was
going to compete against like paper you
are going to compete against Zuck
Craigslist and like hundreds and
billions of dollars of invested Capital
into this
I just don't think it's it's not a safe
bet it's not a good bet
yeah really good points there and
something to work on for sure and by the
way I would say uh like when I was in
college our first idea was uh it's
always this this and roommates well no
this would have been better than my
first idea the one we did at straight
out of college was like a sushi
restaurant chain to try to create a a
restaurant chain and like
um it was the same thing we could be 10
out of 10
um execution 10 out of 10 creativity
like fundamentally like restaurants are
like you know sort of like a two out of
ten opportunity it's like one of the
worst types of businesses you can try to
start and you know so we had a point
where a year in we were like cool we won
this businessman competition we we can
do this it's not that we can't do it
we're having success with our first
location but like
we got to remember this is just our
first idea maybe we're more
entrepreneurs than we are restaurateurs
and maybe this first idea is the one
that got our wheels turning but let's
not commit more years to something if we
Rec once we recognize that this is a two
out of ten opportunity we should just
say okay cool let me guess
be a college kid let me have my
opportunity my time back and let me put
it on another better opportunity and so
that's what I would do if uh if I was
you but just FYI getting 93 000 of
transactional value to prosectional
volume is super super super impressive
that is amazing so maybe you could prove
us wrong and be like and you said two
out of three tickets you just be like
look we're just gonna build a different
Stub Hub and it's gonna be better
because we're marketing Wizards and who
knows why it's gonna be better maybe
you're gonna prove us wrong but 93 000
and 2300 users in a three months
incredibly impressive that is wildly
impressive so you're you're also a
superstar I'm just gonna I don't know if
you're gonna pull it off in this genre
but we'll see yeah awesome thank you
guys so much uh as a closing note like
if you have any advice on this it seems
like the of the people that do use our
app
um you know they almost exclusively use
it to sell their tickets and other
things if you decide not to bail I would
stick with tip kits and stick on that
for at least one year and talk to users
constantly and see what happens but I
would stick with tickets but and I
wouldn't even worry about expansion I
would just figure out what makes them
come back over and over and over again
because I imagine if I had to look into
StubHub and seat geek CAC is the biggest
issue and I'm just guessing I've not
researched this yep all right Dolan
thank you so much um and all right we
pick a winner we pick a winner now so
that is the uh my first million presents
University of Michigan pitch competition
super impressive caliber of
entrepreneurs like I said
um love this community you know Bobby
Bobby my bi-weekly killer good job
putting this group together
um we gotta pick a winner so Sam how do
you want to do this I think also let's
talk about uh like who's in the top
three and then you and I slack with me I
just slacked you my top two you and I
slack and just tell me uh what you want
to do and I'll tell you if I approve and
I agree with your vote but basically um
let's go let's go in order so third
runner-up uh or like you know but maybe
made my top three I guess uh I just give
you give you three in a random order so
um I liked Seafarer like I said I want
to actually invest in that I think that
that's a a really cool idea going into a
boring boring industry that's
painful complicated and
I think you know not going to be easy to
sell into but if they do very easy to
get lock in and I think they can make
money doing basically payroll for the
shipping you know shipping industry for
people who work on ships so I really
like that idea
um internet activism was super
impressive they you know have built a
website that got 600 million users they
uh built an Airbnb thing for Ukrainian
refugees that had a hundred thousand
people stay you know in homes that's
kind of it's just crazy it's ludicrous
and that's a career maker just that I
mean that number and just the idea of a
non-profit that's not uh driven by you
know what nonprofits are driven by today
which is sort of like fundraising and
sales and marketing it's like we're
hackers we just build stuff that's going
to help help people and that's what we
do and I I really kind of resonate with
that
um I've seen the power of that one time
um the guy who was investing in our idea
lab he was like Hey I want to do this
thing for this charity I support called
charity water
you know but instead of just giving
money what if we gave our talent what if
we built something and we built a
charity website that was designed to go
viral it was like could you make charity
go viral that was the mission we spent
three months on it and I remember we got
I don't know five million people to like
come visit the thing and we raised I
think 800 000 for the cause
um and so like I've seen how Builders
can help charity in a way that's kind of
unique and then
um
and then also Jake from tabs chocolate
who's doing the NFC tagging thing I
thought that was another good one I
think I think a cut below the other two
but a honorable mention what do you
think I agree entirely I think Jordan
just did a really good bad job of
pitching and but I actually think that
that business is actually really
intriguing and could be great I think
it's just a boring software company that
I like I think it could be a really
great business uh but he was so bad at
pitching that it ruined the fact that
it's a cool company I think uh and I
actually think that he's got a lot he
doesn't have as much traction as
Internet activism but if he does
actually have 30 or however however many
said 20 customers using his software I
think that's a fairly pretty big deal
because it seems kind of hard to sell
into them so
um I sent to you what I think should be
the winner it's the last thing I said do
you agree or not agree
um I don't agree I think it should be
this other one what do you think okay so
let's just say who the top two are yeah
top two we got are Seafarer and internet
activism
so
internet activism
[__] amazing this guy made me want to
quit and join him my issue with him not
him my issue with giving them the money
is they already have a great thing going
and they're kind of crushing it it feels
weird giving this money to a non-profit
uh I'd rather just give them my own
personal money but he is so impressive
that I was I I this guy's gonna be uh on
the cover of Fortune or Forbes I think
in the next five years so I'm I would be
fine giving them money but Seafair it's
an idea man we could just be the first
money in to actually make them like
build something so that's why that's
interesting yeah I I feel the same way
but I think for C4 I would put my
personal money in as an investment but I
think for the prize money of this I
think that if we put it into internet
activism it's going to save lives and uh
and honestly like he was of the bunch he
was the most missionary and like you
could just tell like for example the
guy's a Visionary all these other people
I feel like if I talk to him six months
from now they could be working on
something completely different
and that's totally normal and okay
especially if you're in college I
actually encourage that but when you
know you know this guy was like kind of
aggro where he was like you know
um yeah I could go work on a CRM tool or
it's like whatever but like you know
after that I'm doing this and that is
something I really really respect I
don't he was looking for validation I
think he was trying to get the word out
and so that I respect that dude I looked
up one of the co-founders of Internet
activism on Twitter and
um he uh his background picture was Zuck
was Mark Zuck given the middle finger
and
I used to have that same background and
so I'm on board man uh I agree with you
we'll give it to internet activism I
think that they are awesome I think all
the folks here are are were incredibly
impressive dude the one that we [__] on
the most I think was deal dog the guy
got ninety three thousand dollars a
transactional value in three months like
no one does that very impressive all
around kudos to everybody and I gotta
say we're not picking interactivism for
the do-good like the guy's pitch was
dope his first line where he's like you
know people in poor communities have
have more access to cell phones than
they do to toilets right he his pitch
was good his traction was good we built
things that have gotten hundreds of
millions of visits right
um his idea was a big idea of encrypted
messaging app that can't be shut down
basically an Unstoppable messaging app
that's gonna help people in certain
places right and I think he was the most
committed founder that's why not because
uh to charity just give them the money I
also think he's a [__] I think these
guys are [__] I think that these
guys are like uh the good type of
[__] I think that they're the
people who I'm gravitated towards I like
people who just like and frankly a lot
of these guys had that Vibe I mean tabs
chocolate from Jake definitely has that
Vibe
um they have this like attitude of like
screw it I'm just gonna do this and
we're just gonna see what we're gonna
find out yes and I love that mentality
this guy just displayed it the best for
this in this particular case but these
guys all had this like punk rock vibe
that I love so
and that's guys that's that's everybody
in this room right now even though rich
man had it yeah
we got
um and Jonathan and Mike when I like
were struggling to take five
um there we we could have had 20 pitches
he was like [__] on the traditional
clubs and like other like official
organizations and he's like no we're the
underground we're the underground real
ones and I I respect that dude this
reminds me I mean they were further
along than us and smarter than us but
when you and I were like 23 24 25
hanging out at your office a monkey
Inferno we surrounded ourselves with
these types of freaks and a lot of them
have gone on to build
literally 20 or 30 billion dollars worth
of companies You Know Jack Smith uh your
boy um furcon uh like these guys have
built like huge uh Ryan Hoover all these
guys have built some really huge
companies and these guys remind us of
this and I think that it's actually I
hope send this to you University of
Michigan they're blowing it man by not
empowering you guys uh so I I think
that's crazy yeah send me a hoodie I'm
wearing a Michigan hoodie on the next
pot I'm I'm a me too you know who else
came from uh University of Michigan was
our boy Michael uh from from future
who's a total that has this exact same
Vibe of just pretty one of the one of
the first members of this organization
whatever you want to call it and uh yeah
this is uh this is credit to these guys
and gals this is not credits University
of Michigan this is uh
what makes this special we love
University of Michigan we do and we're
going to take every single last resource
until we leave this place but until then
a little bit all right well whatever you
want to describe yourself I admire you
folks I think you're awesome I think the
listeners hopefully this gets hundreds
of thousands of listens we'll see I
think this is going to be a hit
um but uh yeah you're awesome so if
people want to find out more do you have
your website what's your website did you
even say that yeah just again it's
internetactivism.org we're looking for
donors we're looking for engineers we're
looking for non-profit organizations to
partner with anything if you think you
can help out or your interest in working
with us just feel free to reach out
again
internetactivism.org and uh the name of
the club is what entrepreneurial Power
Hour my name is Bobby hausel
um you can feel free to reach out to me
and help me build this across the
country all right thank you Sean you got
anything to say we're out of here nope
that's it that's the Pod good job guys
very impressive
[Music]
foreign